methylation pathway and this is what both factors concern themselves with so
we're going to do an empty HFR test on you because that's what a genetic test is
that we have to be able to talk about that halfway but this is the methylation
pathway right here if we looked at a chart your body takes in folate from
foliage, relieving animals goes through these different genes that we have to
look at it ultimately makes this thing right here methyl tetrahydrofolate
who's heard of that? a few people and methyl tetrahydrofolate that goes into the
Bethanyline pathway and makes sand into the other light partners that you have that
you've got to know what about and it goes into the biopterate pathway to make all
your neurotransmitters so your neurotransmitters so it's very important so this
foliate pathway is really important. Bethanyline is the process of trying to
run it off genes to make certain enzymes to for the gene to replicate depending on
what that gene does it has to be methylated and unbethylated in order for
that to turn on and off so making methyl groups is very very important for your
body if we have a deficiency of methyl tetrahydrofolate because in the
dietary deficiency which did occur at the beginning of the first few decades
of the last century the early 1800s greedily imaginables and we're not what
city people were eating they were eating cakes and brands and things like that
right and they were eating whole wheat bread they were eating white bread well
where do you get folate from? if you have a deficiency in folate you're going
to have an deficiency in methyl tetrahydrofolate which is the active folate and one of
the things that it could occur if a woman carried a baby has an deficiency it could
cause a neural tube defect so women were eating any green leafy vegetables if you
were a high class woman you're eating a lot of brands and you certainly were
eating that brown bread you were eating white bread there is folate and
green leafy vegetables there's also a little bit of folate in the wheat germ
of the hull of the wheat so that was stripped off to make white bread there was
no folate in white bread so people were grossly deficient in folate so babies
were being born with neural tube defects and when it was discovered that it was
folate they created folate in the laboratory it's called folic acid so folic acid
is synthetic folate now if you look at the back of your vitamin capsule bottle it
says folic acid and it doesn't say anything else it's synthetic folate now it
makes a folic acid as folate or folic acid as five methyl tetrahydrofolate or
folic acid as folate if it does that then it's okay if it just says folic acid
and nothing else or as folic acid you should take that bottle of vitamins and
throw it in the waste basket folic synthetic folic acid will help prevent
neural tube defects but it is theorized that synthetic folic acid is the cause of
the defect that is so pushed on the market the MTHFR defect so epigenetically it's
thought that folic acid is the cause of a methyl tetrahydrofolate defect it
doesn't work the same as folate it should not be taking folic acid so folate will
turn it to methyl tetrahydrofolate through this folate cycle and then it's used
and several other metabolic pathways still with it this deep gene right down here
that MTHFR gene down at the bottom there is so highly regarded because it was
one of the first ones discovered and there's a lot of research on it there's two
genes there in that family in that bubble there the 1298 gene may be a spot that
it mainly feeds the biopterant pathway to make to make of neurotransmitters and
neuronal and endothelial nitric oxide and the C6-7 gene feeds the
differentiated cycle to make sand which is your made methyl transfer group in your
body to help turn genes on and off and for everything to work so when I have a
patient that comes to me it says why am I on the sinus defect on the C6-7-7 and
T.J. flower so it must it's gonna die you know you're not gonna die okay and you
probably shouldn't be taking a whole mess of it so I and this is I used to do
this a little time ago too so we're gonna put the person on because I used to be
the only gene you could test so we're gonna put the person on methyl tetrahydrofolate
well the problem is that you push those pathways so rapidly if they have defects
in those other pathways you can cause a whole mess of symptoms literally it could
be a catastrophe if you make too much neurotransmitters you are going to have
problems in the case of the two children that I mentioned have our patients if they
would have taken either one of them would have taken I don't remember if they
were ever on it would have taken methyl tetrahydrofolate or other methyl
groups they would have pushed dopamine production very strongly these are the
people that can become suicidal very rapidly or detrimental to society very
rapidly excess dopamine and excess serotonin are going to cause the very
high levels of aggression all right still with me all right so these are the
genes in that pathway we're not gonna go over all of them they're all
important and you see this person has an empty HFR C677 a sigle allele or
headers I guess defect there all right so now making Sam so if I said ATP
making ATP is one of your life goals making Sam is another life goal you need to
make Sam you don't make Sam you're going to die and that's made in this
methionine pathway so starts right here coming from MTHFR through this MTR gene
this is where you recycle B12 this is the 4 Y to 4 of a B12 is really important
in what you're taking we'll talk about that a little bit you get into methionine
here and this is in amino acid that then converts to ultimately to
Sam methionine is really important for cancer patients because if we have
MATG defects that converts methionine into Sam then we can have excess
methionine and cancer can feed off of methionine so this is where when we talk
about cancer diets and what are we going to put this
cancer patient on oh well the person protocol is going to put you on very high
juicine and low meats which is technically similar to a low
methionine diet so the Gerson protocol would probably be very good
for a person who has MATG defects with excess methionine but if the person
doesn't have any MATG defects they don't need to be in a low methionine diet
following it's kind of confusing but the more information that you have
and the more you know the more valuable this can be to a patient
right and again maybe for the average person who doesn't really have much
rub with them this isn't all that important but when you're dealing with
states for cancer patients then light patients that can get better all the
stuff is super super important so looking at these pathways is really
is really important it's so important for you to make
sand which I've learned it out on this picture right here because it's
behind this little picture that you make it through multiple pathways you make
it through recycling homocysteine you make it through recycling
colline you make it through the MTHFR path that has to go through B12
this is why B12 is so important in your body but what form of B12 should I
use it depends on what G defects that you have
so most people that aren't going to go on B12 just go to the store and say how
it eats a B12 and will buy B12 or go to a practitioner and just go
on this B12 it could be cyanoclebalamide which is not a good form of B12
could be methylclebalamide that's methyl groups which you have to be really
careful of because if you push too many methyl groups in a person and they have
defects in that in there by after a pathway which we have looked at yet
you'll push it really hard and you'll make excess serotonin in excess dopamine
so you can't do that so that you have to go into what other forms of B12
a dentoclebalamide yeah maybe a good choice
hydroxychomolamine yeah that could be a good choice too
so looking at the gene profile helps you to get specific how you're going to use
supplementation for that person so how are we going to support that G defect
well this is going to be probably the best choice for you to help push this the
right way hydroxy and adenosial are safe for anyone
either one of those are would say are safe forever anyone
otherwise shelf that's where I find them you can buy them they're readily available
either one of those are readily available
hydroxychomolamine and adenosial chomolamine
yeah I mean I maybe not in the normal health which I don't know
I don't want them to chop there yes
well methylchomolamine turned mercury stored in your tissues to gas
I've never heard that I've never seen any research on that but you do have to be
careful with methyl groups because they're going to push different pathways
so I'm not against methylchomolamine I use it all the time understand
it'll use folate all the time but you have to be careful looking at the whole
big picture of the patient okay and that is that is a
key piece to overusing the supplement too so if if a thousand
micrograms methylchomolamine is good that doesn't mean
5,000 is better that can be a lot worse
and I hate to say it but these are metabolic pathways
and there's different needs that you have depending on the stress of the day
depending upon what you're going through from an emotional standpoint
physical standpoint I or no one could say oh you need
x amount of milligrams or micrograms of this nutrient be based upon your genetics
based upon your organic acid test based on this it changes
with the wind now we do know that this might be a better supplement to take
of this but you know you have to get a good idea and how much you're
supposed to take of that and and the balance of that depending on your
stress level yes speaking of mercury do I have any thoughts on detoxing
mercury he's saying I have three minutes left
so yes I have a lot of thoughts on that so
but it's a complicated issue but we we should talk about it but looking at
those cynerpropy450 pathways because that's reverberated detox
is going to show culprabies right so you want to support those pathways
so there are ways where those I didn't talk about the detox pathway
to support those pathways so there are certain products that will push that
pond pathway there are certain products that will push that cynerpropy
into pathway and you want to support those pathways that can have
defects on those pathways this work gets to the gut again
because your liver can be doing a wonderful job
and making these things water soluble don't be living into the kidney
and you have kidney compromise because you have your reicycle
defects which we'll talk about later for dumping it into the colon
and because you have such horrible leaky gut you're absorbing it right away again
or because you're constipated and you're absorbing it into your colon
even if you don't have leaky gut so you have to deal with the guts
you know at the same time at least you can have a person be constipated
this is where coffee edibus can help too so we put almost all our
cancer patients on coffee edibus because that will help pull stuff out of the
liver it'll help the cynerpropy450 pathways and it'll keep the person
constipated a little bit too okay we do have to break